يجتمع عقل اسرائيل ليبحث المخاطر
الاستراتيجيه في مدينه هرتزيليا بتل ابيب
يعقد المؤتمر السنوي الاسرائيلي يتحدث
رئيس اركان الجيش رئيس شعبه الاستخبارات
ومستشار الامن القومي عن ايران اللغه
واضحه والنبره عاليه نقطتان رئيسيتان يركز
عليهما المتحدثون البرنامج النووي
الايراني وتعاظم قوه حلفاء ايران في
الاقليم قلقوا اسرائيل يتزايد بتغير
الظروف الداخليه والخارجيه في الداخل
ينقسم الشارع على نحو لم تشهده اسرائيل من
قبل بسبب التعديلات القضائيه وفي الخارج
تتغير اهتمامات الحلفاء الدوليين وتشهد
المنطقه تغيرات في التحالفات وهدوءا لم
تشهده منذ سنوات طويله تقع تل ابيب جرس
التحذير من البرنامج النووي الايراني تقول
ان ايران تقدمت في تخصيب اليورانيوم على
نحو غير مسبوق تضع الدوله العبريه نسبه
لتخصيب اليورانيوم خطا احمر لا يجوز
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه تجاوزه والا فهي
تقترب من انتاج قنبله نوويه ما يعني قلبا
للموازين في المنطقه كلها ترد طهران
بالتاكيد على سلميه برنامجها وانها لم
تتجاوز نسبه 60% في تخصيب اليورانيوم
لكنها في الوقت نفسه اي ايران تحذر من رد
غير مسبوق اذا تقدمت تل ابيب خطوه مؤذيه
الى الامام عين اسرائيل على البرنامج
النووي الايراني دائما لكنها ترى الان ان
الولايات المتحده اهملت ذلك الملف لصالح
ملفات اكثر اهميه لواشنطن التوتر الصيني
مع تايوان وخشيه الامريكيين من تكرار
سيناري روسيا واوكرانيا الدعم العسكري
والمادي والسياسي والغربي لاوكرانيا لا
يتوقف ولا اولويه تتقدم عليه في المرحله
الحاليه
تجمدت المفاوضات حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني وتوقفت العقوبات الامريكيه
المتعلقه بالامر حتى العقوبات على ايران
مرتبطه الان بتزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمسيرات وفق الاتهامات الاوكرانيه
والامريكيه هذا التغير في الاولويات
الامريكيه بالمنطقه تصاحبه مصالحات تنزع
من تل ابيب ذرائع تشكيل جبهه موحده ضد
ايران اهم تلك المصالحات التقارب الايراني
السعودي وما لحقه من هدوء ملحوظ في ملفات
كثيره هكذا تبدو منطقه خاليه من الازمات
ما عدا التوتر الايراني الاسرائيلي عين
اسرائيل الاخرى على من تصفهم بوكلاء ايران
ينتشر هؤلاء وفق التحليل العسكري
الاسرائيلي في سوريا ولبنان وقطاع غزه
بدرجه اساسيه في اشاره لذلك يقول
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون ان تل ابيب منتبهه
لما تقوم به ايران حول اسرائيل في سوريا
تحذر تل ابيب من انطلاق مسيرات ايرانيه
نحو اسرائيل ما قد يشعل كبرى في المنطقه
وفي لبنان يجري حزب الله مناورات تحاكي
اقتحام مستوطنات اسرائيليه وفي غزه تشير
التقديرات الاسرائيليه الى تعاظم قوه
الفصائل التي باتت علاقتها بايران اقوى
بكثير مما كانت عليه في السابق هكذا تبقى
اسرائيل متاهبه ومحذره وعنوان ذلك التاهب
والتحذير ايران ببرنامجها النووي وحلفائها
في المنطقه لكن التهديد يبقى لغه التخاطب
الوحيده بين طهران وتل ابيب لغه يحذر
الجميع من ان تتحول الى افعال وردود على
شكل حرب